Ryan Tannehill in his last four games he
joins Russel Wilson is the only
quarterbacks in the Super Bowl era to
have a passer rating of 130 or higher in
four straight games I learned this from
reading Peter Kings column today
football morning in America
Peter joins us now who was this Ryan
Tannehill guy Peter oh I don't know he's
some stranger who I don't think the good
people of South Florida can recognize
it's just look he you know I do think
that when he was in Miami you know he
was he was hurt all the time
and you know that obviously affected
Adam GaSe his you know tenure there but
I think that when you have a running
back who's as hot as as Derek Henry and
you have a team that basically is trying
to win the ball they win football games
you know in a very very own fashion way
which is the way they're trying to win
it
I think that's an advantage to a
quarterback who's kind of and I don't
want to say game manager because he's
made some great great throws but I think
it's an advantage to him because all
they're trying to do he might Raven
wants to possess the ball he wants to be
conservative he wants to he wants to be
a team like the Giants of the night of
the of the 80s and so I think it's it I
think it's a favorable position for a
quarterback to be in I know the Patriots
still leading their division they'll win
their division it appears but how much
concern would you have once the playoffs
start with New England Oh massive they
can't do anything on offense that they
really want to do you know Brady's
getting beat up he you know it was
really interesting when you watch these
games especially a national
you may have so many cameras and they
show the full field view and you look
and you see how many guys like you know
how there aren't people open I guess I
mean I know that it's it's kind of open
season on Brady and I get it but I don't
really know what else you can do and
that plus the fact that you know their
running game is averaging yard less per
carry than it then it ran for a year ago
so I don't know I look at all this dan
and I I just sort of say that you know
and I wrote this morning that I really
think and Romo talked about it yesterday
you know about the gadgets they've got a
they've got to run five or six of those
every game because I really think that
there's no other way that they can that
they can win games now other than by
trying to fool things because you they
can't play team straight ahead and and
either overpower them or you know
somebody's open on every snap help me
understand what Sean McVeigh is doing
now with Todd Gurley because he now sort
of has the light go on this epiphany
that maybe I need to give him the ball
more more touches here I I thought that
this was by design that they were gonna
try to get through the first half of the
season not relying on him too much and
now all of a sudden he decides to go to
him so what am I missing here that Sean
McVeigh all of a sudden brought this to
light
well I continue to think that one of the
reasons why that he wasn't touching the
ball very much is that his knee was not
in great shape and I'm not sure that it
still is but you know he wants the ball
they want to give it to him you know who
knows I think we'll look back we'll know
the answer to this in three or four
years I don't know that we're going to
know it right now hmm because I think if
you're a coach and you're trying to
protect a player
not totally healthy I think you you you
you never never talk about what his
injury is or easy you know or you steer
clear of being very specific about that
and so we'll see but it's hard for me to
believe that a guy who is as good as he
was
you know thirteen months ago that they
purposely would not be giving him the
ball very much and in and look last
night and I think the last couple of
weeks one of the reasons why I think
that they're better is that they're a
little bit more balanced and they're not
putting the ball they're not putting
every game on golf shoulder and you know
I think I think it shows what's
happening the last few weeks that
they're a little bit better when they're
better balanced talking to Peter King
football morning in America it's
available every Monday exclusively on
NBC sports.com if it can go wrong it has
gone wrong for the Browns even in
victory
they sound like they've been defeated
how does this end here Pete and
Cleveland you know I think I think
everybody has an educated guess about it
and one of the things about the Browns
is that they don't really leak very much
John Dorsey as who you know he and Jimmy
Haslem are gonna make these decisions at
the end of the year just from watching
the way we've all watched then I mean
they've been they've been overall now
they've been a sloppy team they've been
a team that always has a fire drill
going on about something they and and so
to me I look at it and and I really
think they're going to change coaches at
the end of the year
and you know the other the other problem
I think there is that it's all well and
good to you know to make it trade let's
use the Odell Beckham
you know for an example it's all well
and good to make a trade for a great
football player but I do think that if
you do make a trade for Odell Beckham
jr. you have to understand exactly what
you're getting
I think the Browns didn't really
understand exactly what they were
getting you know Dell Beckham jr. they
just thought he was a great football
player he's a major diva and that he
requires an incredible amount of a you
know of care and feeding and most
coaches and most teams do not want to
deal with that and I really questioned I
respect Jay Glaser's ability a lot
yesterday and I believe exactly what he
said that that Odell is telling people
get me out of here come and get me well
it's a little bit different now isn't it
than it was a year ago when it was just
one time okay so now it's giant this
year who wronged him and now it's the
Browns again in the span of a year who
who aren't doing him right and are they
really going to be able to get value for
him of any sort I'd be a little bit
surprised quite honestly if they got
anywhere near the value that they think
he's worth if the Browns job is open and
Dallas is open which one do you think
would be more desirable it's a really
really good question
I I mean I think they're I think they're
very very close just because I think the
Browns have an awful lot of Browns have
an awful lot of good players and they
also have an awful lot of cap room the
Cowboys are gonna be really really caps
trapped I would not want to go to a team
that's going to be caps trap they're
going to have to pay their quarterback
they're going to be in camp trouble for
the next few years I probably rather go
to Cleveland
and that doesn't that isn't really
because I don't think that I'd want to
work for Jerry Jones it's because I've
seen how they work and he's not an
impossible guy to work for but I just
think over the next few years it's gonna
be easier to build and to supplement in
Cleveland and it isn't Dallas I
mentioned this to the Danites a little
while ago there's one quarterback who
fascinates me every week because he
giveth and he taketh away
Jameson Jameis Winston and I don't know
if Bruce Arians knows what he has I I
think he likes him an awful lot but I
don't know if he's done enough where you
keep him or you move on in Tampa what
would you do I agree I mean I I think
you here's the problem that I see if you
do not keep Jameis Winston and you throw
them back into the pool you've won a
little bit too much in my opinion anyway
as you start to look at the draft now
who knows what's going to happen but
let's say the Bucs end up winning six or
seven games well you're certainly not
getting Joe Burrell you're probably not
getting too uh and and who knows I mean
there's a bunch of quarterbacks this
year and all that but I happen to think
that you know Dirk cutter fell on a
sword for Jameis Winston for a long time
and everybody thought well there's going
to be tough love now with Aryans but the
fact is Jameis Winston you know
continues to play like this and then
agreed with with venerians not every
interception is his fault
absolutely you know he's had a bunch of
tip balls some fluky things but he still
throws too many he takes some risk that
you shouldn't take so the big question
now is should you give them a bridge
contract and have them for another year
or two and basically say we're just not
positive we can't give you twenty eight
thirty million dollars a year but we'd
be willing to give you
fifty-five million for two years or
whatever the defeating whatever the
contract is that's probably a little bit
too much but well giving it will pay you
a representative sum over the next few
years and then let's make a decision
sometime in the next two years about
whether you're going to stay or go so
that's the tough call that they have the
other alternative I think they think is
that you know there's a couple of
quarterbacks most notably Teddy
Bridgewater what are they gonna do this
year for a while we thought maybe
Chicago maybe Denver would be a good
market there be a market for Teddy
Bridgewater well based on the last two
weeks I don't think either one of those
teams are going to be spending major on
quarterback and disrupting the applecart
that they already have so minoo I don't
think you're absolutely totally stuck
with Jameis Winston but I do think that
there's absolutely no way I'd commit to
them for another four or five years the
only way I do it is on sort of a bridge
contract where we say okay you're our
guy for 2020 and then let's make a final
decision after that Pete good to talk to
you enjoyed the column as always it's a
football morning in America every Monday
exclusively on NBC sports.com Thank You
Pete all ready for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]